whoa excuse me I don't think that was
you that starts with my hole from you
you see he still hugs his parents when
the world falls apart no matter how long
it takes I will history's greatest
heroes this is my first Panthers decades
I don't want to see that
we'll keep it together my mother once
tell me that bad news was just good news
in disguise was this before she
abandoned you yes it was
I'll push them overboard you guys say it
was an accident
I'm in this summer battle station
surrender your ship or face my fury to
work anger management the end of the
world were all gonna survive this okay
maybe they won't is just the tip of the
iceberg
hey little fellas how about you and us
against the Pirates you got no idea what
I'm saying do you may I try
Booga Wooga Wooga Wooga Budda Budda
Budda Budda up no one's gonna stop me
from getting back to my family
come on an ocean is that the best you
can do
ice age continental drift
you're pretty soft our Sabre scuse me I
happen to be a remorseless assassin yeah
go poo hey I made you another call
necklace he keeps losing them